hi 3A today I'm going to show you my
favorite moments from cream of mushroom
black forest cake episode my favorite
moment is making ganache so let's make
it first I'm going to heat up heavy
cream just stop right before boiling
alright my cream is hot and I'm going to
pour I love this moment because when I
pour heavy cream a gradually melt
chocolate and when I was whisking it
becomes white to kind of swirl of the
chocolate and when I'm keep whisking it
becomes luscious ganache and it's so
shiny it's so beautiful when I spread
with spatula it's very smooth
and shiny if you want to see more
satisfying Moment Like This check out
our new episode of making fancy